[Música]
el 27 de marzo la asamblea nacional de
El Salvador aprobó suspender los
derechos de la libre asociación y vio la
habilidad de la correspondencia defensa
ante una detención y también ampliaron
el periodo máximo de detención
administrativa dando inicio así a un
régimen de excepción en ese país
centroamericano un régimen que ha sido
extendido Ya seis veces goza de cierta
popularidad entre los ciudadanos pero es
criticado por traer serias violaciones
de los Derechos Humanos que contrastan
con la significativa reducción en las
cifras de homicidios en El Salvador
quienes rechazan la medida afirman que
estos seis meses de estado de excepción
en El Salvador han dejado miles de
detenciones arbitrarias estigmatización
sobre todo de los jóvenes también malos
tratos en las prisiones también hay
denuncias de algunos casos de tortura y
fallecimientos de varios ciudadanos bajo
custodia del estado y que hay también
cierto abuso de poder por parte el
gobierno lo hay pues ya lo vamos a
analizar en unos minutos en el programa
para quienes defiendan esta medida los
resultados simplemente pues son
evidentes según el gobierno salvadoreño
más de 52.000 personas han sido
detenidas y están en prisión en
prisiones que están súper pobladas según
las organizaciones de Derechos Humanos
en particular la organización cristosal
al menos 80 personas que han sido
detenidas han fallecido bajo custodia
del Estado salvadoreño y ahí también
denuncias de entre 2.700 y 3.000
detenciones de personas de manera
arbitraria para los ciudadanos la
tranquilidad o la sensación de seguridad
es la prueba más clara del buen
resultado de esta medida Y eso también
se traduce en las cifras de alta
aceptación que tiene la gestión del
gobierno actual según una encuesta
realizada por la universidad Francisco
gavidia y que respalda o que dice sobre
el respaldo que tiene el mandatario
sobre este tema
la popularidad del mandatario ronda
cerca del 80% de aceptación por parte de
los ciudadanos según la firma Sid galup
el 85% de los salvadoreños también
aprueba las políticas gubernamentales en
términos generales no solamente en
términos de seguridad sino también en
materia económica salud en política
exterior etcétera esa misma firma
consultora Indicó que en esa misma
encuesta que realizó el 95% de los
ciudadanos aprueban las acciones que ha
adoptado el gobierno salvadoreño para
enfrentar la inseguridad desatada por
los grupos delincuenciales conocidos
allí como maras y han aprobado también
la prolongación del estado de excepción
que como dijimos ya lo han prolongado
seis veces y también aprueban la forma
en que se está dando esta lucha contra
la violencia en ese país
qué hacer entonces con estas denuncias
de presuntas violaciones de los derechos
humanos Esto le jugará en contra al
gobierno del presidente bukele quien Ya
dijo que va a buscar la reelección en el
2024 está en riesgo la institucionalidad
y la democracia Salvadoreña o este es
tal vez el precio que tiene que pagar el
Salvador para poder tener un poco de
seguridad y tranquilidad por lo menos
entre los ciudadanos y Cuanto más se
mantenga está alta popularidad del
presidente pues mejor le va a jugar al
presidente para mantener y llevar a cabo
su plan de seguridad y también sus
diferentes políticas que ha buscado
implementar a lo largo de su gobierno
por eso hoy analizamos la situación que
se está viviendo allí en el Salvador
tras seis meses de estado de excepción
es nuestro tema de debate hoy aquí en
France 24 para conversar analizar sobre
este tema hemos invitado a Eduardo
Escobar el este director de la ong
acción ciudadana se conecta en esta
oportunidad desde la Ciudad de Santo
Domingo en la República Dominicana pero
desde El Salvador en la capital La
Salvadoreña se conecta Francisco
Martínez él es consultor en temas
sociolaborales también es asesor del
Consejo Nacional de desarrollo
sostenible es Monitor de cumplimiento de
los ods en el Consejo Nacional de
desarrollo sostenible de El Salvador
nuestros televidentes ustedes las
personas que están viendo Este programa
también pueden participar en esta
conversación en este debate pueden dejar
todas las preguntas comentarios que
ustedes quieran hacer sobre este tema
los invitamos a que las hagan a través
de las redes sociales ustedes ya saben
estamos en Twitter en instagram en
Facebook en donde nos encuentran como
arroba
france24_es y @santilogo que es mi
cuenta personal la etiqueta para que
dejen sus comentarios se las recuerdo es
numeral el debate f24 también en YouTube
usted puede ver la señal en streaming no
solo de la cadena y del programa Sino de
todas las programación de France 24 y
También aprovecho para saludar a las
personas que nos están escuchando a
través de nuestro podcast todos los
contenidos de este programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast Spotify
deezer y tuning
comenzamos Y entonces lo hago dándole la
bienvenida a nuestro primer invitado
para comenzar a analizar este tema
comienzo con Eduardo Escobar en la
Ciudad de Santo Domingo en la República
Dominicana Punto de partida Como me
gusta Llamar a la primera pregunta para
conocer las opiniones de los invitados
Eduardo Gracias por acompañarnos en esta
oportunidad y seis meses después de la
instauración de la constante extensión
de este estado de excepción en El
Salvador sigue siendo un acto
inconstitucional sigue siendo visto Así
pese a la favorabilidad que le da el
gobierno y que le da también la
población a las medidas que se han
tomado a lo largo de estos seis meses
Cuál es su análisis Bueno gracias
Santiago por la invitación un gusto yo
creo que este tema lo podemos ver desde
tres perspectivas la jurídica la
ciudadana y la política si nos centramos
en lo jurídico aplica lo que usted
estaba señalando hay una
inconstitucionalidad de este régimen de
excepción porque en la Constitución está
pensado el régimen de excepción para
otro tipo de situaciones de gravedad que
enfrente el país estamos hablando de
terremotos Huracanes etcétera etcétera
no estaba diseñado el régimen de
excepción para un tema delincuencial que
no digo que no sea grave pero que no era
digamos una de las causas para aplicar
un régimen de excepción ese es un primer
punto siempre no jurídico este régimen
viola derecho fundamentales y viola
tratados de Derechos Humanos porque
estamos hablando que se le suspende por
ejemplo el derecho a defensa técnica
durante un período de tiempo a los
detenidos también hay que decir que hay
herramientas jurídicas ordinarias que
tenía disposición El Ejecutivo para
combatir a las pandillas pero no se hizo
había un plan de control territorial que
no estaba teniendo efecto precisamente
porque probablemente no existía Entonces
el punto acá es que se están dando una
serie de violaciones que ponen entre
dicho la existencia de un estado de
derecho en El Salvador en tema político
brevemente hay que decir que el gobierno
tomó la medida más fácil la que le
facilitaba enfrentar a las pandillas y
digo esto porque las causas
estructurales de la existencia de las
pandillas en El Salvador no han sido
atacadas entonces ahí hay un tema que
creo que es importante debatir cuán
sostenible en el tiempo puede ser estas
medidas y no se atacan las causas
estructurales
perfecto la opinión de nuestro invitado
Eduardo en la Ciudad de Santo Domingo
paso a darle la palabra y también la
bienvenida del programa a Francisco
Martínez en la ciudad de San Salvador
Francisco bienvenido Gracias por
acompañarnos también El Punto de partida
esto sigue siendo visto como algo
inconstitucional algo que ha venido
siendo manipulado por el gobierno de
turno a su favor para poder llevar a
cabo esta política de seguridad que de
acuerdo a las cifras que presenta el
gobierno ha demostrado ser en cierta
forma exitosa y también se va reflejada
en la aceptación por parte de los
ciudadanos Cuál es su análisis Gracias
Santiago bueno Saludos Eduardo un placer
saludarte no sé por qué estás tan lejos
Espero que estés trabajando Espero verte
pronto por acá Bueno sin duda creo que
hay una valoración diferente
particularmente si se atienden los temas
por las ramas yo creo que este era un
problema fundamental diagnosticado desde
hace más o menos 20 años El Salvador
tenía dos grandes problemas para
enfrentar su ruta de desarrollo uno el
tema de la delincuencia de la violencia
delincuencial y dos el tema del valor de
sus transables bienes y servicios uno
vinculado al otro necesitaba en algún
momento entrar al fondo del
enfrentamiento del problema central que
es la delincuencia y en ese sentido este
gobierno ha tenido la valentía después
de todo entrar al problema de fondo sin
andarse con medias tintas creo que eso
es sin duda uno de los puntos políticos
de mayor decisión que se ha tenido por
parte de esta administración por en
diferencia a las anteriores ahora creo
que uno de los puntos uno puede entrar
en un debate legal uno puede entrar en
un debate sobre la jurinicidad de
ciertas cosas el artículo 29 es claro
este es una situación que pone en riesgo
la continuidad del Estado porque pone en
riesgo permanente a la ciudadanía creo
que Eduardo tendrá que revisar un poco
la situación de todas las comunidades en
las que la vida se cometía una serie de
tropelías la gente era comunidades tenía
que vivir en una situación de zozobra
permanente sometidas juzgada a la
violencia pandieril de organizaciones
que han sido declaradas terroristas por
la sala de lo constitucional por lo
tanto esto era digamos la necesario
enfrentarlo con toda la el vigor del
Estado ahora uno debe tener en cuenta
este es el enfrentamiento inmediato el
problema no sólo puede no puede ser solo
resuelto partir del combate directo sino
que hay que crear condiciones esas
condiciones son la continuidad de un
programa que buscará Y eso en eso hay
que trabajar mucho mecanismos para que
las comunidades salgan de una situación
de pobreza histórica que haga hacia la
que ha sido sometida a nuestra población
a partir de un modelo de injusticia
permanente Entonces es un problema
jurídico la está digamos este régimen
amparado en lo que la Constitución
Establece en su Artículo 29 un buen
jurista lo puede estudiar y puede dar su
opinión de manera muy objetiva en
segundo lugar había que tomar una medida
Esta es la medida más inmediata el
gobierno puede correr costo políticos el
resultado de lo que dice la población Es
que la población ha respondido de forma
positiva frente a esta medida que el
gobierno toma y por fin la sociedad está
empezando a ver hacia el futuro hasta
hoy la gente cuando tú le preguntabas y
pensaba en el futuro decía no porque
estaba sometida a vivir el día a día su
juzgada con terror y sometida
presidencia que las pandillas
terroristas ejercen en diferentes
territorios en el país entonces frente a
eso el que estamos ahora que hay una
situación sin duda los datos que se
tiene son de que el eh se han tenido
52.000 detenidos de estos 53.485
detenidos hay
47.893 que están en detención
provisional O sea que hay cerca de 5.600
detenidos que están o bajo medidas
especiales digamos de acuerdo al marco
jurídico local o han sido digamos
ninguna responsabilidad en los problemas
que se por fueron detenidos Eduardo
recojo algunas de las palabras que acaba
de decir Francisco en esta primera
intervención me llama la atención algo
que dice él y es que el panorama que
estaba presentando El Salvador y estos
hechos de inseguridad que se estaban
presentando ponían en riesgo la
gobernabilidad la
el desempeño del Estado salvadoreño la
democracia y también estaba poniendo un
jaque a la sociedad que estaba
prácticamente en medio de esta lucha con
las maras para usted también estaba ese
escenario así de crítico estaba al país
en riesgo
debido al tema de la inseguridad que se
estaba viviendo allí y que justificó
este estado de excepción
no yo creo que si bien concuerdo con
Francisco igual le mando un saludo no no
estábamos al punto de un estado fallido
porque digamos un escenario tan extremo
hablaríamos de un estado fallido si bien
teníamos territorios de la república que
estaban bajo el control de las pandillas
que eso no hay que negarlo todos lo
sabemos pero el estado como como tal No
es que estaba al borde de dejar de
funcionar y colapsar porque creo que si
no no era ese escenario que sí era un
problema sumamente delicado que había
que atender concuerdo con eso no se
había hecho de la forma adecuada pero el
señalamiento que ahora hay que hacer es
que por qué el gobierno no lo hizo de
entrada porque hasta ahora actuaron
porque hasta ahora está 56.000
detenciones hay alguna respuesta ya a
esto periodismo de investigación
encuentra por el faro por ejemplo
digital del Salvador que existe un
acuerdo con las pandillas por parte del
gobierno entonces por eso es que se dio
la baja de homicidios y que con según el
faro al romperse ese pacto es que se dio
el alza a domicilios que obligó al
régimen de excepción el punto acá Creo
yo que hay que decir la ciudadanía que
si bien puede tener un alivio temporal
no sabemos cuánto tiempo va a aguantar
este alivio o sea
extendido en el tiempo será y lo segundo
que es difícil hacerle ver a la
población salvadoreña porque está
asediada por una serie de problemas el
hecho de cuando el gobierno actúa de
forma discrecional rompiendo la
Constitución pone en riesgo los derechos
de la gente ya hay hay ciudadanos que
expresaban en redes sociales su apoyo al
gobierno por estas medidas pero luego
fueron detenidos o un familiar sí
Entonces el punto es hay que decirle a
la que el gobierno tiene que combatir la
criminalidad sin duda Pero dentro del
marco del Estado de derecho Francisco ya
lo dice Eduardo esto tiene un impacto en
la sociedad en el país es una solución
que desde su punto de vista según lo
dice Eduardo no es sostenible en el
tiempo que tanto más se puede prolongar
este estado de excepción en El Salvador
qué tanto músculo político tiene el
gobierno para sostener estas políticas y
todo este rechazo que está empezando a
ver por parte de organismos
internacionales y de gobiernos
internacionales
Yo creo que mayoritariamente la
población está en función de que esto
continúa eso digamos es una opinión que
las encuestas lo recogen eso en primer
lugar en segundo lugar la situación Por
supuesto No es una situación ya
finalizada el problema delincuencial
estaba enraizado desde diferentes
análisis se mostraba que era una
estructura muy bien establecía en el
territorio Eduardo conocerá a muchas
comunidades en donde era totalmente
difícil poder entrar a menos que
tuvieras algo conducto o amistades en
los grupos familiariles para poder
ingresar a ellos de lo contrario era en
verdad una situación o era un infierno
para las comunidades creo que lo que la
población está empezando a mostrar hoy
es esa esa situación de confianza de
seguridad y te dicen que hay que ya no
hay pandilleros en la calle te dicen que
la situación ha mejorado y por lo tanto
te dicen que estarían dispuestos a que
esto este régimen de excepción continúe
cuánto va a continuar esto es una
decisión política al esa decisión
política estará a la base de los
análisis de criminología nuestro
análisis de la del control delincuencial
de la incidencia que este sigue teniendo
sobre la ciudadanía lo que sí es
importante y Eduardo no me dejara mentir
es que esa ola de crímenes contra la
ciudadanía ya era una situación
intolerable insoportable ahora que creo
que hay que hacer diferencias una cosa
es vivir bajo un régimen de sección en
una situación de un estado que ejecuta
esto conforme al poder y no lo puedo
hacer este gobierno en los primeros
meses de su gestión porque no tenía no
tenía la correlación para eso Hay que
crear una correlación política que le
permita la votación suficiente que le
que que apruebe un régimen de sección
como lo dice la Constitución hoy lo
tiene Y por supuesto tiene los dos
tercios de la asamblea legislativa Y eso
le permite imponer este régimen de
sección para poder controlar la
situación de delincuencia que ya se
había desbordado y por otro lado hay que
diferenciarlo de lo que es una situación
de de régimen de sección o Estado de
sitio como lo que vivimos en el marco de
la de la situación política social de
los 80 y de lo que es la situación de
tortura yo fui preso político estuve fui
capturado por los viejos cuerpos de
seguridad fui torturado en las cápsulas
en la cárceles del régimen fui
básicamente liberado por la presión del
pueblo y la persistencia de mi familia
Ese es una situación totalmente
diferente Eso no es la situación de
ahora lo que hay Es un régimen de
excepción donde el estado A partir de
las reglas del juego que establece la
Constitución impone un mecanismo que le
establece la Constitución con el poder
que tiene el poder y la correlación El
poder del Estado incorpora una serie de
mecanismos para enfrentar de fondo el
problema de la delincuencia con lo cual
la ciudadanía se siente satisfecha y
poco a poco esta ciudadanía va pensando
va viendo Más allá del día a día le
permite a la gente entender que la
situación era tan complicada que ya
necesitaba algo que la resolviera esto
si todavía no es la solución definitiva
después hay que hacer una fuerte
inversión social y con Eduardo
coincidiremos en que esas comunidades
están tan deprimidas que necesitan
social empleo y necesitan que la gente
sienta seguridad y armonía para poder
desarrollarse en paz y en tranquilidad
Francisco usted habla de reglas del
juego habla de mantener la
constitucionalidad pero aquí hay serias
denuncias de violaciones a los Derechos
Humanos hay también hemos visto
manifestaciones ciudadanas en las calles
de San Salvador precisamente rechazando
la prolongación de este estado de
excepción que dice usted de estas
denuncias que hay por parte de
organismos no gubernamentales incluso
críticas de un gobierno como el de
Estados Unidos que es un gobierno muy
cercano y me atrevo a decir sumamente
necesario para El Salvador justamente
por la gran diás por la salvadoreña que
vive en ese país norteamericano
si hay denuncias se hay hechos si hay
pruebas hay contundencia en lo que se
está digamos denunciando ahí están las
instancias pueden hacerse digamos la
denuncias respectivas y acudir a los
tribunales para poder pedir justicia yo
creo que ese es un punto en el cual no
hay ninguna situación que pueda obviar
ahora se argumentará una serie de
situaciones de que esto no es posible
por una o de otra razón Lo cierto es que
ahí están los espacios para poder
demandar esto es una situación muy
diferente a la que vivimos en los años
80 sobre la participación del del de la
opinión del gobierno de esta Unión un
tema de doble Morales o sea en lo cierto
Es que para El Salvador era necesario
tomar una decisión política que
enfrentada de frente El problema
fundamental que evita el desarrollo y la
convivencia armoniosa de la sociedad
principalmente en las comunidades más
pobres Esto es lo que implica esta
decisión tiene una decisión política
amparada en el marco constitucional del
país entiendo Cuánto se va a mantener lo
que sea necesario lo que el análisis
político le responda al gobierno Ahora
sí yo reitero para poder avanzar hacia
un país a un país en desarrollo para
poder concretar una visión que le
permita a la ciudadanía tener visión de
Progreso pensar en el futuro enfrentar y
resolver el problema de la seguridad era
hoy hoy era el punto importante y la
decisión había que hacerla ya lo ha
hecho y eso le permite a este gobierno
tener una simpatía importante se hace
Francisco Francisco
de que ser un problema medular a
resolver Eduardo su opinión sobre estas
palabras de Francisco
yo no no concuerdo con Francisco en
algunos aspectos el primero el que tiene
que ver con cuánto tiempo va a estar
esta medida Acá hay que ver dos cosas
uno es el gobierno va a mantener la
medida mientras le signifique réditos
electorales ya viene la elección y en
esa medida el gobierno sabe que este
tipo de acciones Pese a que sean
constitucionales que violen el estado de
derecho le genera apoyo ciudadano y por
lo tanto la va a mantener mientras eso
siga ya vemos quienes vemos que esto se
puede extender hasta cerca de la
elección ese es un punto o sea no hay
una análisis
criminológico de por medio sino que aquí
lo que estamos viendo Es le tiene
beneficios en el ex para la elección se
va a mantener eso es un tema Por qué
digo esto porque no se están atacando
las causas estructurales de la
criminalidad de las pandillas no se está
haciendo eso Entonces ese es un punto
que para mí me parece importante y lo
segundo es que no se va a quitar este
régimen de excepción porque las
instituciones del sector de justicia son
débiles no tienen la capacidad
suficiente para combatir este este
flagelo que tenemos como país y en esa
medida tampoco se está trabajando en
fortalecerlas o sea teníamos una
fiscalía general de la república que
generaba un 90% de impunidad un órgano
judicial con una mora judicial Pues
también alta con poca investigación
científica del delito Entonces ahora con
esta medida y como digo han venido a
suplir esas carencias pero no con
recursos no con capacidades sino que
facilitando el procesamiento de todos
estos criminales pero vuelvo y pregunto
qué va a pasar el día de mañana las
capacidades institucionales se
fortalecieron va a poder mantenerse el
estado de
sus territorios Ese es el punto Ese es
el punto que expone Eduardo desde la
Ciudad de Santo Domingo Eduardo continuó
con usted para hacer la ronda a la
inversa porque cree usted que se está
presentando este escenario particular
que puede uno ver desde fuera de las
fronteras salvadoreñas Y es que Tal
parece que el gobierno de turno Y en
cierta forma la ciudadanía al respaldar
este tipo de medidas adoptadas por el
presidente bukele da la sensación que
dejan de lado el tema de Derechos
Humanos dejan de lado el tema de la
Constitución de la Constitución
salvadoreña y y se juegan el todo por el
todo por tratar de garantizar
la seguridad de los salvadoreños Aquí
hay una mancorna bien lograda gracias a
una buena estrategia del presidente
entre gobierno y sociedad para que esto
pueda seguir navegando esta medida del
estado de excepción
yo creo que más que eso es
aprovecharse de la población y digo
aprovecharse de la población Por qué
los salvadoreños hemos sufrido a las
pandillas o sea yo no estoy diciendo que
eso no sea un problema que era urgente
atender Pero el punto es que el gobierno
ha aprovechado esa necesidad de la gente
para sacar un beneficio político
electoral ese digamos el punto más que
armar una alianza con la población fue
un tema más de aprovechar las carencias
las necesidades de la población sobre
este tema y como tenemos una sociedad
con una cultura política autoritaria una
sociedad con graves carencias de de lo
básico una sociedad es informada
una sociedad con poca educación cívica
todo esto hace una mezcla para que se le
aplauda este tipo de medidas al gobierno
que violan derechos humanos o sea y el
gobierno ha sido hábil y yo digo ha
engañado la gente ha sido hábil
haciéndole aceptar que puede perder los
derechos y que no habría problema con
que los pierda con tal de ganar
seguridad y eso solo lo vemos en
regímenes autoritarios populistas donde
se le ofrece a la gente seguridad A
cambio de restringirle sus derechos y
ese es el problema de nuestra sociedad
salvadoreña que la población eso no lo
logra entender vende su libertad por un
par de monedas prácticamente Francisco
su opinión Aquí hay un cierto beneficio
político para el presidente de cara de
esas elecciones y aprovechándose este
contexto que presenta la sociedad
salvadoreña que describía Eduardo qué
piensa usted
yo creo que hay que tener en cuenta una
cosa el problema estaba el problema era
grave el problema necesitaba enfrentarse
de raíz Y enfrentarse con toda la fuerza
del Estado para poder ocupar toda la
fuerza del estado se necesitaban con
relaciones políticas se necesitaba una
institucionalidad orientada para poder
enfrentar sin ninguna duda este flagelo
que ya tenía la sociedad rodillada eso
es lo que se ha hecho qué es lo que uno
tiene que tener en cuenta para eso se ha
hecho en el marco del de la ley y la
constitución en el artículo 29 y yo lo
insisto Eduardo creo que hay que hacer
una lectura correcta de eso para poder
precisar que se trata de un mecanismo
legal que para poderlo usar necesitas
por supuesto tener dos tercios en en la
votación legislativa este gobierno lo
construyó lo tiene A partir de ahí da
una respuesta firme decidida que al
final le permite a la ciudadanía poder
respirar y pensar más allá del día a día
ver la diferencia ve la importante que
eso tiene tú conoces comunidades que son
muy flageladas por el tema de la
violencia delincuencial pandillas esa
gente ya no podía pensar en un día más
pensaba en el día como yo salía y cómo
llegaba en la noche frente a eso que ha
habido la respuesta ahora esto tiene
réditos electorales pero no somos
ingenuos esto es política o sea se trata
de que si un gobierno hace bien las
cosas recibe el apoyo el beneficio de la
gente esto está claro Un gobierno cuando
define un programa y ejecuta una serie
de medidas las hace Buscando el favor y
el beneficio de la ciudadanía Eso es así
aquí y en todos lados lo que pasa es
Cómo lo haces lo haces pensando en crear
un estadio diferente en donde se
presente oportunidad de desarrollo
futuro o lo hace simplemente para
favorecer tus tu réditos políticos
personales no yo creo que hay una
diferencia en esto hay una visión ahora
que es este grupo político que está
gobernando el país que tiene más pensado
una lógica de trascender de este hoyo en
el que estaba El Salvador y saltar a una
situación en la que controlando la
delincuencia pandillarín terrorista
asegurando un nuevo una Nueva Visión
sobre desarrollo impulsando una
transformación del Estado para generar
fortaleza institucional y generando
mayores valores y espacios de la
ciudadanía se pueda llevar adelante un
modelo de desarrollo sostenible que
asegure ante todo y por sobre todo la
posibilidad de que la ciudadanía vive en
tranquilidad que tenga prosperidad que
vea hacia el futuro que pueda sentirse
bien y no solo hablamos de los
salvadoreños que vivimos acá hablamos de
los 10 millones de salvadoreños por todo
el mundo los siete que vivimos acá y los
tres millones que están fuera yo creo
que ahí hay una diferencia y por eso yo
creo que los salvadoreños que están
afuera cuando vienen al país se sienten
tan congratulados de que las cosas están
cambiando yo solamente para para que
tengamos en cuenta lo siguiente cuando
yo hago ejercicios con diferentes
sectores uno de los puntos que le
planteaba era Cuáles eran los problemas
más críticos que teníamos hace dos años
el tema de la delincuencia era
prioritario porque son trabajadores son
gente de las comunidades Por supuesto
que el problema central Cuáles crees que
aparecen ahora en el tema El problema
del empleo el problema de los ingresos
pero ya no aparece el problema de la
violencia familiar O sea que esa
sensación es un paso importante que
asegura la posibilidad de cambio en este
país Tan tanto que lo necesitamos tú y
yo que hemos hecho diferentes acciones
de lucha social sabemos que esa era una
medida que había que tomarse y este
gobierno la ha asumido con toda la
valentía requerida y con la
institucionalidad que permite la
Constitución Eduardo así las cosas y
entendiendo este panorama como ustedes
dos han expuesto aquí a lo largo del
programa había otra forma en la que el
gobierno del presidente bukele podría
haber dado respuesta a esta necesidad de
combatir la inseguridad de las maras
allí en el Salvador qué otra opción
podría haber tomado el presidente Para
poder haber hecho frente a este flagelo
Claro que habían opciones y yo a
diferencia de Francisco
señaló que no necesitaba la correlación
legislativa para hacer esto por qué
Porque El Ejecutivo tiene a su cargo la
seguridad pública tiene la Policía
Nacional civil el Ministerio de
seguridad y muchas de las cosas que se
tenían que hacer ya tenían las
herramientas para hacerlo voy a poner un
ejemplo las mismas autoridades de
Seguridad Pública han señalado que ya
tenían mapeadas a las pandillas ya
habían quienes eran sus cabecías a donde
operaban qué delitos etcétera Por qué no
procedían contra ellos acá se dice es
que mire los jueces estaban a favor de
las pandillas porque los liberaron pero
Habría que ver un tema la fiscalía
general de la república no tiene ni
tenían las capacidades para investigar a
disputar adecuadamente a los pandilleros
delitos el órgano judicial igual Habría
que ver si ese era el problema de que
los jueces eran corruptos pero a lo que
voy yo es que el gobierno tiene control
de eso de hace más de un año tenía
control de esto y por qué tomaron las
medidas de régimen de excepción porque
se dio un alza en los homicidios si esa
alza no se hubiera dado no estuviera en
estos 56.000 pandilleros detenidos no lo
estuvieran Por qué Porque el gobierno no
estaba implementando medidas para
combatir a las pandillas Porque si
seguimos lo que dice el faro es porque
tienen un acuerdo Entonces digo si no se
hubieran dado esos 86 fallecidos que 85
no recuerdo la cifra en dos o tres días
el gobierno no hubiera tomado esta
medida y por eso es que yo señaló que al
final no necesitaba De nada el gobierno
necesitaba la voluntad de compartir a
las pandillas y no lo había mostrado
Eduardo continuó con usted para hacer la
ronda a la inversa vemos que el
presidente bukele está siendo uso de
esta popularidad que tiene entre los
salvadoreños para llevar a cabo estas
políticas algunos dicen que está
llevando a máxima atención la
Constitución ese aprecio por parte de
los ciudadanos y también la popularidad
que tiene entre los diferentes
organismos del Estado esta bukele
jugando con fuego y llevando a máxima
atención y esta delgadísima cuerda
podría reventarse en algún momento
en un futuro no muy cerca no muy lejano
este gobierno desde su inicio ha hecho a
un lado la Constitución ha pasado por
sobre la Constitución ha hecho a un lado
principios de transparencia de hecho el
régimen de excepción ha generado más
opacidad en el manejo de las cosas
públicas por mencionar un caso Entonces
tenemos un gobierno que no respeta
principios democráticos que no respeta
el estado de derecho entonces
a lo que nos lleva es a una supresión de
derechos de los ciudadanos y a un
sistema a un régimen autoritario a eso
es lo que a lo que vamos en el país y lo
vamos haciendo de forma acelerada
nosotros ya vemos que el Salvador se
puede convertir en la siguiente
Nicaragua ya hay muchas señales ya viene
la reelección viene luego la la reforma
constitucional luego viene la supresión
de la oposición etcétera O sea a eso nos
estamos nos está llevando este gobierno
me quedan ya pocos minutos para
finalizar el programa voy entrando en la
recta final Francisco quiero hablarle de
otra Arista que tiene en este tema allí
en el Salvador y es justamente el
hacinamiento carcelario los derechos
para estas personas que están detenidas
en las diferentes cárceles en El
Salvador también Hay muchísimas críticas
y Qué tanto está trabajando el gobierno
en la implementación de programas de
reinserción social de dar la educación a
estas personas que están allí detenidas
que son programas que tienen que ir
paralelos a esta detención y privación
de la libertad pero ya se habla de una
crisis carcelaria la vuelta de la
esquina y en El Salvador
Primero quiero referirme a lo que decía
Eduardo o sea cuando tú dices con con
esta normalidad 83 fallecidos en un fin
de semana Hay que ser la norma O sea
estaba tan normalizado que ya no asusta
o sea mira mira como este complicado tú
mismo lo expresa O sea qué pasa 83,000
murió por eso había que hacer esto que
se hizo no 83 83 salvadoreños perdieron
la vida en un fin de semana producto de
la acción delincuencial de este grupo
terrorista que son las pandillas en El
Salvador ante eso había que actuar la
actuación fue la correcta dimensionada
en función de ese problema que si no lo
frenabas en ese momento tenía una
situación de desbordamiento como una
amenaza para el estado y para la
sociedad eso en primer lugar en primer
lugar creo que hay que hay que dejar
claro o sea ahí
53.485 personas que han sido detenidas
en este proceso
47.893 están en detención previsional
provisional Qué significa eso que hay
cerca de 5.600 personas que digamos
dejadas en libertad ya sea con medidas o
porque sus procesos se va a continuar
fuera de los tribunales es un punto
importante no 56.000 sino
53.485 esto por un lado por otro lado
hay que tener en cuenta de que sin duda
Hay un problema que es un problema
estructural que tiene que ver con la
falta de oportunidades que la sociedad
salvadoreña ha enfrentado frente a eso
hay que reaccionar O sea no puede ser
que por la acción delincuencial de una
pequeñísima parte de ciudadanos de este
país que prefieren de limpiar ya han
ocupado una serie de argucias para poder
poner la sociedad en una situación de
terror que han usurpado las funciones
del estado es una sociedad que fue
descuidándose de de la de la sociedad de
la población para poder imponer sus
reglas o sea el punto es hoy la
prioridad es sacar a las grandes
mayorías de su situación complicada sin
duda Hay que darle una respuesta por eso
este gobierno está haciendo un nuevo
complejo carcelario para atender
justamente a esta importante cantidad de
haber tenido particularmente a los
vinculados con los grupos terroristas de
pandilla creo que estamos frente a una
situación nueva estamos obligados todos
los ciudadanos a poder poner una
situación crítica y a ver este problema
con la mayor objetividad creo que eso
cuesta hay que hay que ver la narrativa
de los hechos pero también hay que ver
la Constitución y las leyes en un marco
de vida bastante crítico y sobre todo
con mucha objetividad me queda un par de
minutos para finalizar el programa
quiero hacer las conclusiones con
ustedes dos comienzo entonces con
Eduardo Eduardo que sigue entonces de
aquí en adelante para El Salvador qué
podemos ver en los próximos meses bajo
este marco de el estado de excepción que
debe ser renovado en el mes de octubre
si así lo decide el gobierno
yo creo que va a continuar y y insisto
porque le genera un efecto electoral al
gobierno intentaron hacer esto con el
bitcoin no le funcionó no generó apoyo
no motivó a la población Pero en cambio
este tema del régimen de excepción si le
está generando apoyo Entonces lo van a
mantener en la medida que sus mediciones
porque hay que decir algo el gobierno no
funciona por políticas públicas sino que
funciona por encuestas eso lo mueve
Entonces si la encuestas aparece todavía
bien Esto se va a mantener yo lo que veo
entiendo que puede ser al final sujeto
de responsabilidad internacional los
funcionarios actuales en tribunales
internacionales Francisco rápidamente su
conclusión 20 segundos por favor muy
puntual
yo creo que se tomó la medida en el
tiempo oportuno es la medida más
oportuna y más digamos apegada al marco
legal que tenemos es la que abre la
posibilidad que los salvadoreños hoy
puedan ver hacia el futuro y puedan
salir de esa preocupación del día a día
de si van a seguir viviendo producto de
la acción terrorista de las maras en El
Salvador creo que se abre oportunidades
y de Progreso gracias gracias
por por haber estado con nosotros en el
programa es todo por hoy En nombre del
equipo técnico les agradezco la sintonía
la producción del programa estuvo a
cargo de Pedro Ruiz y la producción de
invitados a cargo de Tania Herrera
Muchas gracias por su sintonía y sigan
con France 24
[Música]